vsauce kevin's here
playing one of the deadliest games ever
created
so deadly in fact that i needed balloon
kevin to act as a proxy
for me real kevin
i'm real kevin the game is
russian roulette you probably already
know
how russian roulette is played
traditionally a single round is put in a
revolver that holds
six cartridges the cylinder is spun so
that it's impossible to know which
chamber will be
fired you pull the trigger and
there's a five out of six chance that
you are safe
and a one out of six chance that it goes
really badly for you i've inserted a
single needle into each dart so that in
our version of this game
it's gonna go very badly for poor
balloon kevin and that's dangerous
and unsafe this whole thing is dangerous
and unsafe and against the terms of
service for every site
on the internet thankfully russian
roulette is
mostly used in movies as a dramatic
device and
i'm using it as a dramatic way to
analyze probability the important
part is that you never do any of this
ever okay okay
i want to figure out the best way to
survive this
notoriously fatal game so if balloon
kevin plays a standard game of russian
roulette
he has one in six odds of permanently
deflating
his dome there's about an 83 percent
chance that my
rubbery little clone wins and a 17
chance he loses forever
and that's that so here we go it's time
to test your luck
balloon kevin
wait let's make this scenario a little
more
complex let's say that there are two
balloon bursting missiles inside
six chambers with two possible spherical
air sac splattering darts
that have been placed next to each other
adjacent there's a two out of three
chance that my
air-headed doppelganger survives on a
random pull
of the toy so do you like your chances
boy
you think that sharpie mustache is
better than the real deal
well let's see if fate is on your side
the two out of three survival chance
comes through
so it's on to the next round my gaseous
twin has had
a bit too easy of a chance up until now
the
survival math has been very very
straightforward he's had
no active role in deciding his own
fate so let's give him something to
think about
for round two i'm gonna give him a
choice and place
the life odds in his pipe cleaner hands
the choice is this now that he's managed
to survive
one round of the game does he want to
spin
the cylinder before playing again or
does he just play and hope for the best
the big question is is it better for him
to randomize the cylinder or continue
playing with its current configuration
well answer the question punk what's it
gonna be you blue
beanie wearing balloon buffoon
[Music]
given that there are two adjacent
cartridges in there and the
toy has been fired once already does it
even matter
mathematically whether air kevin spins
or
not let's find out the first option
spinning it's the same scenario with the
same
math you're basically recreating round
ones odds which we know
give you a two out of three chance of
survival
so not really a whole lot to consider
there but if you don't spin
you know something else the
toy has just been fired on one of the
empty chambers
which is how balloon kevin survived to
get to round
two and a little logic reveals the math
of whether to
spin or not spin think about the
positioning
there are four possible empty chambers
and only one of them is directly before
the two cartridges which means there's a
75 percent chance that round two's
trigger pull is on
another empty chamber and just a 25
chance that this balloon is about to go
ba-boom by not spinning balloon kevin
has earned himself about
eight more percentage points of
survivability
and it's such a straightforward
probability calculation
because we know that the darts are
adjacent if they were just randomly
placed in the chamber
then things change
here's how there are 15 possible
positions for
two darts randomly arranged in six
chambers
six of them are adjacent so darts would
be in
one and two two and three three and four
four and five five and six
all the way to six and one there are six
more ways that there can be a
single space between the darts so one
and three
two and six one and five four and six
three and five
two and four finally there are just
three ways that darts can be
opposite one another one in four three
and six
and two and five
if beluvin survives the first round
and he doesn't know whether the darts
are next to each other
or spread out does he want his second
shot with a spin or with no spin
we know that we have a 75 chance on
surviving those
six adjacent positions for the cylinders
that have darts
one space apart two of the four empty
positions come
before and empty and two of the four
come before
a dart so that's fifty percent
and it's the same for the opposite darts
[Music]
our overall safety probability here is a
calculation of those
weighted probabilities and it goes a
little something like this
6 over 15 times 3 over 4 plus 6 over 15
times 2 over 4 plus three over fifteen
times two
over four three over ten plus one over
five plus one over ten
equals three over five by not spinning
here
we have a sixty percent chance of
survival
compared to 66.67
percent two over three when we do
spin when we
know the darts are adjacent we can gain
eight percent survivability when we know
they're random we can
avoid losing about seven percent
it's not some magic solution that allows
balloon kevin to survive what's probably
humanity's most
deadly game doing the math doesn't
unveil a secret way to win 80 percent of
the time it
just doesn't work that way it could get
you
eight percent and eight percent's
pretty insignificant isn't it no it's
not
consider this 0.1
of dna is responsible for all the
differences you see
amongst humans and only 1.3 percent
separate
us from chimps 1984 was the last u.s
presidential election with more than an
8 percent
popular vote gap improving road safety
by eight percent would save
96 000 lives per year
a one thousand dollar investment growing
at eight percent compounded annually
doubles in just nine years and
ultimately if you're an incredibly
attractive balloon with
nice big googly eyes a perfectly
formed cotton ball nose and surprisingly
muscular pipe cleaner arms that finds
itself locked in a life or death game of
chance
you'll take any advantage you can get to
avoid
being popped and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you